there's a quote that said changed my
life it said sometimes on a way to a
dream you get lost and find a bigger one
you're a little bit lost right now it's
kind of where you are not that you're
lost everybody many people would love to
have your life being lost right now so
there's got to be gratitude and
perspective but you expect more from
yourself and you feel like you can do
more you can contribute more and you can
go to a whole different level um i
love operating businesses okay so for
example i sit with my goldman guy
and we just had a nice multi nine figure
exit four weeks ago so we're sitting
there and
you know he's saying so what do we want
to do with this we're talking to blacks
black you know we're talking all these
guys on what to put a portion of money
in
and he said and i said so how much is
this going to give if we put 50 million
dollars here what is this going to be in
10 years and and don't give me the best
case scenario give me the worst case
he says that 50 could potentially be 100
million 10 years from now
that doesn't excite me i said what's the
best case is that maybe it's going to be
125 million so he doesn't even tell me
the 50 is going to be 300 million like
over exaggerating he's being very
straight up he's a very conservative guy
so i said okay cool he says patrick this
is during dinner he said the most
amazing thing to me he says pat no
matter what you put your money in with
us
nothing you're doing right now in your
life is going to make higher returns
than whatever you operate
look what he said whatever you operate
because operating i know how to grow and
scale a business you know how to operate
and grow this this didn't go to where it
did by pure luck you have a system
behind it you're a data guy you're a
numbers guy you're all that stuff right
sooner i found that i'm an operator
that's my game
i'm not a guy that's going to build a 17
billion dollar real estate portfolio
that's not my game i'm not a guy that's
going to go out there and you know be
the next bitcoin guy and talk i'm a
maximal you know i'm not that guy i'm an
operator i like starting businesses
building businesses you got to take a
piece of paper and write out for
yourself
what excites you what are you very good
at
and match those two if what excites you
matches what you're very good at that's
that's that's peaking yeah if if what
i'm doing
i'm an expert at is this but this
excites me as well as this that mattress
i'm solid but
sometimes like i've taken three breaks
creating content three breaks creating
content one was at uh you know uh uh
20 000 subs when was that 455. one was
at 1.5 and one was at 3.2 that we took a
break we took those three breaks
and i think sometimes just like johnny
carson fallon just like these guys got
to take a break and just go away and say
hey what are we going to do who's the
next guest what are we going to do with
this part what are we going to change up
are we going to add something new to the
show the same thing's going to happen
because if the product becomes the same
over and over again and you're not
recreating with the times changing so i
have a guy comes up to me i'm not going
to mention his name but you'll know who
this guy is we're having a conversation
together
and he says man my youtube channel
went from having we went from 200 000 to
a million and a half subs in 12 months
and we were getting millions on top of
millions of views 25 000 people would
stay alive when i was doing any kind of
thing and i'm lucky if i get 50 60 80. i
said yeah i said can you pull up those
videos that did very well he pulls up
the videos i said okay 5g
masks kovit
no one cares about those three today
nobody does
and you still want to talk about 5g
masks and covet
once you go into a certain box like that
and you don't adapt quickly you're gone
so as content creators we have to
constantly recreate ourselves if we
don't you're like that person that was a
motivational speaker in the 60s and 70s
and 80s and still saying the same
message from 60s 70s 80s nobody cares
today they respect you
you got to kind of adjust or else you're
going to be left behind yeah sometimes i
feel like i lose that sharpness though
after so many years when you don't have
that same level of focus and that same
drive as you did when it was new and
because of that you have a harder time
adapting true but you're not 72.
it's true you're young how old are you
you're 32. you're 32 years old like you
you know like you're like
just so you know like your next 20 years
is you're you're like
the next 20 years you're gonna do
a hundred times what you did the last
ten years it's not even close
so you mean to tell me i'm gonna wake up
one day i'm 22 32 years old i got a
channel that's got four million subs
another one that's got 880. i've got a
few billion online views i'm everywhere
you know i'm respected people calling me
from i have a good net worth i've done
well for myself i have a voice that's
heard by tens of millions of people what
do i now want to do with this voice i
will tell you
if it's just subs you'll eventually get
bored but if i want to do xyz with this
it'll excite the hell out of you if you
enjoyed this video i give a keynote a
few weeks ago in las vegas specifically
on the topic of cracking a code to
content creation if you've not seen it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]